wie ist die lage
also augenblicklich könnte sie kaum
besser sein ja sitze hier in einem
durchaus entspannten stuhl in der sonne
und
freue mich dass ich hier aber du hast
familie und bist aber jetzt in köln
unterwegs wie lässt sich das vereinbaren
ja das ist eben ein
wie soll ich sagen das bringt halt
dieser job mit sich im arthur zu sein
man man ist dann eben doch zum teil
einige tage am stück getrennt von der
familie du warst polizist wer ist es
gerne wieder also im moment ich war
polizist im moment ist es ist es noch so
dass ich
das nicht bereut habe er gott sei dank
wenn es so gewesen wäre dann hätte ich
eben versuchen müssen zurück zu gehen
solange es noch geht aber im moment bin
ich schon stehe schon noch hinter der
entscheidung trotz der dass das
trotz der anstrengungen umstände zum
teil also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
bei der polizei war es auch nicht immer
und stressig aber doch dann entspannter
aber im moment ist es so dass ich nicht
sagen würde ja gerne wieder polizist vor
allen dingen nicht in stuttgart
wie verfolgst du das als jemand der das
ja auch von anderen seite kennt du
wolltest ja in sek das war so hallo du
bist aber recht gut informiert er ist
das wissen ja nach hin und langem hin
und her habe ich mich dann erhält
natürlich für die comedy entschieden
irgendwie was haben deine eltern dazu
gesagt ja natürlich erstmal jetzt bist
du blöd dass ich so bekloppt also ich
war gut man muss dazu sagen ich war halt
schon beamte auf lebenszeit ja also dann
müssen sie ausgibt genau und das kann
man ihnen kann man sich schon vorstellen
das ist natürlich da
die die eltern verständlicherweise dann
erst mal sagen das ist jetzt mit dem
schon wieder los und
aber es war dann so auf der anderen
seite hat dann haben dann auch
irgendwann gesagt gut ok irgendwo muss
man auch gucken dass man halt so eine
zufriedenheit erlangt ja und nach den
ersten auftritten bei denen sie dann
auch dabei waren und wo sie gesehen
haben okay
da passiert halt war auch was ja und die
leute haben ihren spaß und so weiter
dann war das schon wieder etwas etwas
relativiert haben die gesagt im moment
ist ein frei gewähltes schicksal hält
sag ich mal selbst gewähltes schicksal
und ist alles gut so aber ich bin halt
um auf deine frage zurückzukommen ich
sag immer
verwurzelt damit letztendlich und habe
auch den den blick auf die dinge und
kennen wie du sagst ja tatsächlich auch
sehr gut eigentlich wenn man so will
beide seiten und umwelt am konkreten
beispiel stuttgart zu bleiben ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin froh da
als polizist nicht eingesetzt worden zu
sein weil ich wusste wirklich nicht
ob ich letztendlich diese
ich glaube ich weiß es schon also ich
denke nicht dass ich diese
zwangsmaßnahme in dieser form dort
durchgesetzt da muss dazu sagen so wie
wenn ich richtig informiert bin waren es
größtenteils auch gar nicht tatsächlich
stuttgarter kollegen die dann da so
wirklich massiv vorgegangen sind ich
weiß aber auch aus der eigenen erfahrung
man muss wirklich immer das in der gänze
betrachtet man ist so bilder sind
schnell heraus gezogen aus dem
zusammenhang und dann ist es zeit die
brutalen bullen aber man muss eben
wirklich immer die vorgeschichte auch
dazu berücksichtigen wobei ich ganz
ehrlich nach meinem eigenen gefühl sagen
muss dass es da in stuttgart tatsächlich
zweifelsohne dass da viele wirklich auch
kann man das nie wieder kommt die liebe
über die stränge geschlagen sind und
einfach als polizisten auch jetzt sitzen
beide auf der schulter wie schön der
anderen
überfordert waren einfach auch mit der
situation weil es waren ja wirklich
augen scheinen nicht das war jetzt nicht
irgend so eine großdemo vom schwarzen
block sondern es waren augenscheinlich
wirklich menschen wie du und ich
irgendwie ja die der wirklichen
bedürfnisse haben etwas kunst zu tun und
dafür nicht es ist einfach da muss man
eben doch wirklich hinterfragen okay
kann ich als volksvertreter ja wenn man
das wort nach außen sondern dann
wirklich der das volk vertreten soll und
als entscheidende politiker bzw und und
dienstherr dann irgendwo dahinter stehen
und das in dieser form durchsetzen oder
muss man da nicht wirklich nachdenken
okay
das scheint es schon wirklich etwas mehr
als nur unter den nägeln zu brennen wenn
wirklich immer mehr menschen dazu kommen
aus aus der kompletten
gesellschaftsschicht letztendlich und da
ihre ihre ihre sorge ihre unmut eben
auch eine stimme verleihen und das
eigentlich auch kundtun ja und dann also
ich war sehr erschüttert muss ich sagen
dass dann teilweise wirklich ja so ich
sage man einfach sich mit ihm irgendwie
in tränen aufgelöst waren oder ältere
damen die sich an die kriegszeit zurück
erinnert gefühlt dann weise natürlich in
der in ihrem bisherigen leben niemals
mehr mit so einer form von von wie soll
ich sagen eine aggression oder auch
gewalt oder zwangsmaßnahmen konfrontiert
wurden ja und dann das dann miterleben
wie dann menschen teilweise wirklich
schwerst verletzt werden also ich denke
diesen einen mann der eventuell sein
augenlicht verlieren wird das ist schon
ziemlich ziemlich bitter ja und
da muss ich sagen schieben man sich
schon so ein bisschen
dafür und und hat als auch die sorge
dass wieder ein bild geprägt wird was du
grundsätzlich eigentlich nicht stimmt
aber ist das natürlich wieder öl in das
feuer derer die halt ohnehin sagen die
bullen sind eben los ja da stellt sich
die frage wenn man die bilder sieht ist
das nur ein polizei taktischer fehler
gewesen weil die sind ja wozu wir sehen
sie mal ganz anderen thema aber trotzdem
ist das nur polizei taktischer fehler
gewesen sind die zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort falsch informiert gewesen
oder was ich mich frage gibt's hooligans
bei der polizei
ich sage es mal so um es mal vorsichtig
zu formulieren die polizei ist
letztendlich auch nur ein spiegelbild
der gesellschaft und du hast natürlich
du hast in jedem beruf menschen die dort
eigentlich fehl am platz sind so und in
dem ein oder anderen beruf fällt es halt
mal schwerer ins gewicht unter anderem
wahrscheinlich auch mal bei der polizei
und und ich weiß selber dass es leider
auch menschen gibt die als polizisten
halt ja unterwegs sind aber
meiner meinung nach
eigentlich hätten was anderes machen
sollen oder
ja also
weil sie immer der grund du bist
hilfsbereit und sportlich deshalb in
vista ich bin beeindruckt ist wirklich
sehr gut es war also das ist ohne flachs
ist klingt immer so flapsig aber das
waren tatsächlich die argumente die
damals fielen ja also darum gehen was
kann man machen ja murat du bist so
hilfsbereit und sportlich einigermaßen
bist du auch polizei wäre doch was und
es war tatsächlich das klingt sehr
ideologisch und blauäugig aber es waren
tatsächlich die gründe weil ich nach wie
vor diesem beruf so ansehe dass es also
ich für mich hat dieser dieser begriff
des freund und helfer ist wirklich
eigentlich immer die größte wertigkeit
gehabt und ich bin sehr glücklich und
dankbar darüber dass ich zumindest sagen
kann mit wirklich reinem gewissen dass
die menschen
bei denen ich zwangsmaßnahmen sage ich
mal angewendet haben das gab kam
durchaus dazu also wir haben uns in
berlin oftmals wirklich auch klappen
müssen so ja aber ich kann zumindest es
wirklich mit reinem gewissen sagen das
ist die menschen
die haben alle noch ihre augen die haben
ja da hat glaube ich nicht mehr so eine
richtig gute nase aber ich kann
zumindest sagen dass es die aggression
immer wirklich vom gegenüber war und ist
immer eine reaktion war und das
gerechtfertigt und auch
angemessen war ja und wir erleben leider
das ist gerade im aktuell dass das
oftmals nicht so der fall ist ich finde
da sollte man sich als polizist wirklich
sehr individuell doch wirklich seiner
seiner verantwortung bewusst seien ja
und sich noch mal wirklich mit sich
selber auseinandersetzen okay und ich
weiß das ist echt schwer ist wenn man in
so einem pulp ist und es ist natürlich
ein extrem stressige situation und du
hast bis dahin mit einer gruppe zum
beispiel aus einem zug heraus man mit
mitte 20 30 mann und du hast halt
hunderte tausende gegenüber die halt
auch wenn natürlich ihren das ist ja
auch so die entladen natürlich ihren
ihre wut und ihre verzweiflung wer bei
dir weil du bist in dem moment als
uniformträger repräsentiert zu den start
und es geht natürlich an dem
entscheidungsträger der dafür
verantwortlich ist eigentlich vorbei in
dem moment sondern dass lee and entlädt
sich natürlich bei dir und dann hast du
diese stresssituation und nicht jeder
ist natürlich da so in der lage diesen
stress entsprechend damit gut umzugehen
und ist dann oftmals überfordert der und
dann fängt man halt an irgendwie aus
seiner not heraus sehr nur weil einer im
zuruft schämt euch das verfasst brett zu
zücken und darauf zu reagieren so wenn
man sich bedroht fühlten dieser hat das
ein sehr komplexes thema da kann man
könnte man stundenlang darüber
debattieren ja ich finde es ist immer
wichtig man sollte beide seid natürlich
berücksichtigen in der gänze auch der
situation aber auch für mich muss ich
sagen es ist jetzt gerade echt schwer
und ich finde es wirklich schade in
welcher form dar
agiert oder so was hast du in solchen
situationen gemacht weil ich es gibt ja
viertel da kommt man mit dem
streifenwagen rhein ist zu zweit man hat
stress wird jemanden und plötzlich hat
man die stress mit jemanden sondern da
sind 40 mit dicken stress hat was macht
man da als polizist also bei 40 war
gottseidank also bei 40 war ich noch nie
alleine ich wäre wahrscheinlich dann
weggerannt ja
bevor ich die es gibt ja dann auch die
möglichkeit und was machst du wenn das
ist wirklich eine bedrohliche situation
ist ernst du weg oder ziehst du halt
eine schusswaffe und drohten den
schusswaffengebrauch an zum beispiel in
der not werk war aber du musst ja dann
auch schießen zu breiten durchlass
bereit auch bereit sein zu schießen das
muss man ich meine damit muss man sich
als polizist natürlich auch
grundsätzlich auseinandersetzen ja ich
habe gott sei dank die schusswaffe nie
anwenden müssen gegen menschen ich hatte
sie zwar schon diverse male in der hand
und auch schon im anschlag aber musste
gott sei dank nie schießen ja da bin ich
auch froh darüber
aber ansonsten war es halt so wie gesagt
das ist ja immer das ding wenn du im
normalen dienst irgendwo hin dass du
weißt nie was für ein bekloppter hinter
der wohnungstür ist und ob es denn
wirklich weiß ich auch schon erlebt der
durchgeknallte dasteht mit der axt
irgendwie und dem alles egal ist ja das
gibt es alles und ich wie gesagt mir ist
das gott sei dank immer gelohnt ich habe
immer versucht die leute ich war so ein
bisschen dafür verrufen schon fast die
situation halt wie soll man sagen tod zu
quatschen so also einfach zu langweilig
mit dem moment
war immer die kollegen
jetzt kommt aber im jeweils also für
mich mal der größte größte erfolg wenn
dann der der größte brutalste irgendwie
irgendwo irgendwann gesagt hat hj
eigentlich hasse recht sohn und dann
sich am besten noch freiwillig hätte die
handfesseln anlegen lassen das war
sodann triomphe er ich habe mich jetzt
nie davor gescheut irgendwie auch vorne
wenn es nicht zu vermeiden war von einer
körperlichen auseinandersetzung dann
muss das halt auch so sein und dann habe
ich das auch in
aller härte durchgeführt so aber wie
gesagt dann ging es zu mindestens immer
vom gegenüber aus und ich hatte in dem
moment keine andere wahl und dann musste
er letztendlich dann auch mit den
konsequenzen leben ich bin mal gespannt
bei youtube wo sich auch viele bekloppte
die kommentiert
cluster weise mittäter kommentaren so
was sie dazu sagen da bin ich mal echt
gespannt das ist nämlich auch da ein
weites feld ich glaube da sind so ein
paar trotz
dieser ja klar es wird er ja gut es wird
immer immer so aber wie gesagt das muss
glaube ich letztendlich wird es immer
welche geben die haben halt ein
gefestigtes bild und für diesen
für die sind alle bullen halt einfach
nur brutale schweine soja weiß natürlich
blödsinn ist und auf der anderen seite
gibt es natürlich auch wieder sagen die
sagen zu die ist halt jeder
demonstranten prozent potenzieller
straftäter was natürlich auch blödsinn
ist sonja und das prallt mehr oder
weniger so ein bisschen an mir habt da
müssen die leute wenn sie der meinung
sind sie müssen dann halt da oder
weniger so dinge führen müssen sie es
machen ich kann wie gesagt und das ist
das glück dass ich habe wirklich ohne
mich wiederholen zu wollen sagen okay
ich bin mit mir selber im reinen ja und
und jeder der mit dem ich mal
aneinandergeraten binnen der dann
ehrlich zu sich selbst ist würde es auch
so bestätigen jetzt machst du comedy
über deine die sich sehr mit dieser zeit
auch als polizist beschäftigt denkst du
manchmal wenn du eben so was siehst wie
stuttgart
eigentlich müsste ich mehr kabarettist
sein es gibt ja da eben polizist seien
ja unglaublich viel
politisches
pulver also ich finde diese diese
trennung ohnehin wird immer schwieriger
da zwischen komik und kabarett so er wo
siehst du ziehst du denn als ich dachte
ich als komödie bezeichnete
leute die da geht dann ja ja
ich habe da gar kein problem ich würde
mich auch eher als comedian bezeichnen
allerdings versuche ich schon auch so
ein bisschen was zu transportieren also
das ist immer so
ich denke man kann wenn man selbst zum
beispiel so ein soloabend von mir sieht
kann man durchaus sich einfach leicht
unterhalten lassen und und geht dann
hoffen hoffentlich gehen meistens gott
sei dank von unmut ist einfach nach
hause und freut sich dass man netten
abend hat ein bisschen gelacht haben
damals ok man kann aber auch wenn man
dafür empfänglich ist und die
wahrnehmung hat kann man eben auch so
ein bisschen zwischen den zeilen lesen
ja und dann kann man durchaus sagen okay
das ist halt comedy mit wenn man so will
kabarettistischem einschlag oder
zumindest der ein oder anderen message
oder den dem so einen denkansatz dem man
vielleicht mit geben will also haben die
fernsehredakteure auch schon gesagt
mitternachtsspitzen hatte ich schon
eingeladen da kommt ja nicht nur also da
ist er schon gehts warum das war ja
schon so
ein bisschen der ritterschlag sage ich
mal so als comedian und dann noch immer
also relativ in den anfängen quasi
mitternachtsspitzen oder bei der bei der
jahresabschluss galaform
scheibenwischern dann ja stimmt dabei zu
sein ja war schon ich meine das war
natürlich schon die leute haben auch
erst mal gedacht so ja was was was ist
das jetzt hier verändern aber es hat
funktioniert
es ist ja auch immer die frage welche
zielgruppe treffe ich comedian in
anführungszeichen ich sag mal ist so bis
35 wenn ich kabarettist bin in aktives
zeichen oder das etikett tragen dann
geht das los ja genau und wie
überschneiden sich eigentlich nicht mehr
und ich versuche eben dass das
unmögliche möglich zu machen dass es
eben sich überschneidet und so ein
bisschen
ineinander greift und jetzt wirst doch
noch serien-star wenn ich das richtig
sehe ach ja gut ist das absolut weil die
leute sagen wer ist murat topal wer
kennt den schon und ich sage moment
weil es ist ja also wir haben jetzt
abgedreht eine eine eine serie für sat 1
comedy erstmal als probier plattform
sozusagen ja als einen spartensender
wenn man so will
aber ich glaube und das sage ich nicht
weil ich der hauptdarsteller mit sondern
weil ich glaube weil ich wirklich glaube
es ist schon eine ziemlich coole nummer
und zwar ist das eine action comedy halt
acht teile
action comedy gab es bisher noch nicht
ich habe sich also in der
deutschsprachigen raum zumindestens gab
es auch noch nicht ja und
das heißt
spiel im uhrturm spezialeinsatz ja und
ja also wie gesagt durch aus meiner
meinung nach durchaus freetv tauglich
aber man muss nur gucken das ist wäre so
ein bisschen sich in der
fernsehlandschaft auskennt weiß dass es
von so vielen
unbeeinflussbaren oder schwer
beeinflussbaren faktoren abhängig sagen
immer nur
redakteure ja deswegen sind wir auf
youtube
das ist halt so ja und aber wie gesagt
schauen wir mal ich bin sehr gespannt
ich habe aus einem kleinen kleinen
abschnitten auch das noch nicht gesehen
aber ich denke dass das hat wirklich ist
was cool ist also ich spiele mich selber
im prinzip ich spiele einen polizisten
der
von seinem chef gespielt von rolf zacher
ja also es kommt noch hinzu dass der
cast auch bei uns gewesen
sehr lang das längste also die
auszeichnung war drei stunden
also gut dann kennst du dir muss man
nicht mehr viel zu sagen und er spielt
mein chef halten und es war echt eine
bereicherung für die ganze sache als
sehr viel spass macht wir sind immer
noch in regem kontakt und hoffen dass
wir weiter zusammenarbeiten können weil
deshalb das passt einfach zusammen
johanna glaube ich sehr gut harmoniert
auch hinter der kamera was der schau
stellen schauspieler der unglaublich gut
mit seinem gegenüber islam tischtennis
spielen kann das kann der sensationell
bälle hin und her geben lässt der
brilliante und und der eben es gibt in
dieser serie gibt es einmal den konflikt
hält zu ihrem prinzip man so will
zwischen meiner frau und meinem chef in
meiner frau will natürlich dass
pünktlich zu hause bin ja unter anderem
hochzeitstag oder will mal dass wir mal
wieder urlaub mache und mein chef der
verteilt mir immer ganz ganz absurde
spezialaufträgen also ein
spezialeinsatzkommando
der meistens dann so ein bisschen
augenscheinlich oder im ersten moment
nach hinten losgeht ich krieg das nicht
hin schaffst dann aber doch irgendwie
dadurch entsteht eben dieses dieses
komödiantische elemente und das ganze
ist gespickt halt mit wirklich möchte
ich sagen doch zum teil recht
hochwertigen action-sequenzen sondern da
sind coole sachen dabei und das was mich
sehr gefreut hat ist dass wir es
wirklich so realisieren konnten dass ich
die sachen eben auch wirklich selbst
gemacht habe sobald also wenn du die
schule mache ich nicht gejubelt wurde
quasi und auch das noch mal als als so
als so ein bisschen als kleine
besonderheit der zu zeigen ok mensch der
ist der kann das ganze ja noch
einigermaßen lustig sein und macht aber
auch noch andere sachen und kennst du
eine geschichte vom chef von action
concept die ja ja ich weiß
action concept chef und jemand sollte
aus dem hubschrauber zu springen und er
hat so verhalten gemacht weil da oben
sich die hubschrauberflüge drehte und
dann hat er da mal gezeigt wie das geht
sprang so heraus ja und dann fehlt
erhalten stückchen schade war auch wird
glaube ich nicht weg ist aber nicht
irgendwo in der pampa hat zwar gefunden
formale ja aber das ist nicht passiert
das ist mir nicht wenn ich mir noch
nicht aus dem hubschrauber gesprungen
ich bin von einem von einem außen
flugzeug bin nicht gesprochen allerdings
ja
aber da war der rother nicht oben
sondern der propeller vorne von daher
ist die gefahr geringer dass ist und ich
hatte auch mal gut dann viele zu den
geheimtipp noch wissen auf jeden fall